trois visages 23 femmes elle s'appelle
marine jennifer au rachel elles sont
agricultrice pompiers soignante
toutes ont été en première ligne dans la
crise sanitaire
derrière l'objectif la photographe
orléanaise géraldine à rester à nu elle
est allée à la rencontre de chacune de
ces femmes selon lui de travail elle les
a photographiés avec une idée en tête
montrer ce que toutes ces anonymes ont
fait pour les autres
il en résulte des clichés en noir et
blanc tout en sensibilité plein de force
et de vie parmi elles il y à marion 7
infirmières travaillent à l'hôpital dans
les ans au service réanimation elle a
pris la pose devant la chambre d'un
patient que ses collègues étaient en
train d'un tube et cette photo pour elle
c'est une reconnaissance pour le travail
accompli
j'essaye de représenter mes collègues et
montrer qu on a fait ce qu'on pouvait
enfin qu on fait ce qu'on peut pour pour
soigner toutes ces personnes et
que malheureusement des personnes
décèdent mais que quotidien on essaye
vraiment de faire notre maximum pour
pour les gens de les prendre en charge
le au mieux
à l'origine de cette exposition trois
femmes trois élus du conseil
départemental du loiret l'exposition a
pour nom les femmes de première ligne